one third of pakistan is underwater as
flood waters rise across the country the
government says climate change is to
blame climate change minister sherry
huffman compared the situation to a
dystopian disaster movie and said she
had never seen anything like it more
than a thousand people have died
international aid has begun to arrive
but getting to those who need it most is
challenging with some areas completely
cut off
drone images reveal the extent of the
devastation near pakistan's indus river
the floods have destroyed bridges and
washed away many roads
forcing authorities to use boats
military planes and helicopters to carry
out difficult rescue operations
often without a dry spot to land on
the government says one in seven
pakistanis are affected by the floods
more than 33 million people many were
forced to leave their homes returning
only to see what's still salvageable
when i saw the water coming i saved the
women and children
when i returned here there was a lot of
water then i saved the cattle
after that
there was no chance to return here there
was just too much water
the government expects the recent
destruction to be worse than the
widespread flooding of 2010.
[Music]
people have actually lost their complete
livelihood their orchards their gardens
their agriculture fields and crops have
been destroyed we have lost more than 45
percent of cotton crop in pakistan
relief efforts are underway across the
country cargo planes from abroad are
bringing urgently needed food water and
tents to pakistan
yet many flood victims still feel
abandoned by the government
a lot of water entered our village our
homes are submerged
some of our relatives have died
we're not receiving any relief from the
government
there are also concerns about what's
still to come monsoon season isn't over
yet more rain and flooding is expected
over a thousand people are dead in
floods that have destroyed large parts
of pakistan
the government blames climate change
caused by other countries
well to talk about that ali
sheikh is an independent expert on
climate risk management just how severe
are these floods
these are
very serious
the
spread affected
already about
a million houses have been damaged
over a thousand have unfortunately lost
their lives and probably 30 million
people have been touched
uh what we have seen so far is a very
strong capacity of the country in rescue
operations of course it could have been
better but we have done well
i think what is another strength that i
wish to highlight is a very rapid
mobilization of some resources for cash
disbursement please remember that we
have a cache dispersement program we
have done a survey of households many
years ago it's a live database
and we have identified bottom forty
percent of the population and sixty
percent of the population below the
poverty line and in
phase one
we are
trying to read centralization with cash
disbursements uh in addition to
emergency supplies of medicine
food and water
and that is absolutely important one is
that the initial estimate was that this
will be a smaller number of people it
turned out for six weeks of very heavy
rains have left a large number of people
and we will very neat quickly
need to replenish our financial
resources through this vehicle special
purpose vehicle that we have for
disbursement of cash
but the number of houses damaged
tells me that the infrastructure is not
climate resilient
it tells us that we need to do better in
reconstruction
you are a climate risk manager so to
speak these flash floods are often part
of the monsoon season but not on this
scale the government blames climate
change caused by other countries
what's your take on this
well just imagine you go to upper indus
basin
uh people have lost their infrastructure
that was built during last five decades
and 60s and 70s and their glaciers have
outbursted
and their carbon footprint is nominal
they are paying for the lifestyle the
society is spend generally speaking in
terms of permanent laws and permanent
damage to our culture our
our society and our ecosystems so
bottom line is
in the climate change conversation
nobody is safe unless everybody is safe
and here we see that a large percentage
of population
left in low-lying areas in flood-prone
areas they live with very fragile
housing and non non resilient housing
and whenever there is a flood of the
sword there are
huge losses
and some of them them come to our
coastal areas because of sea water
intrusion some come because of glacial
melt others have come because of
torrential rains now and then of course
our infrastructure and flood management
the rainfall management is pretty strong
but we were not prepared for
uh in terms of our infrastructure for
urban urban flooding we were not
prepared for torrential rain of this or
to cause a trans boundary or transit uh
prevents
um flooding of the scale that we have
seen so it's it's a it's a in the
climate change context the footprint of
this country is very small very nominal
um we are on the wrong side of the state
when it comes to climate justice we have
no
calculations done in terms of estimating
the the the climate cost or economy and
that development but this much we know
that each such extreme events such as
heat phase such as droughts and floods
and sea water intrusion and gross
glacial melts the cost of development is
increasing constantly and this is very
hard for a developing country economy to
keep up with this kind of escalating
development
okay it sounds like a lot needs to be
done on on both sides in pakistan and
abroad as far as
battling climate change goes that's for
sure thank you very much for being on
the show alitakia sheikh
you